what are your thoughts on homeschooling
i love it i mean i'm out on the campaign
trail and i can spot a homeschool kid
from a mile away they come up they talk
to you they look in the eye i'll say are
you homeschooled per chance and they're
like yeah i am been homeschooled and
then the mom will say i'm homeschooling
them for three years started with covid
and
really bright kids really right kids
isn't it crazy that uh
the institutionalized learning
facilities funded by our taxpayer
dollars are stunting children and
inhibiting them and that you can see it
in a homeschooled kid that they're
better adjusted more mature you know the
the uh school what are they called the
teachers union they're having their
national um you know meeting right now
and they're can you believe they're
trying to push for masks again
wow this is sick it's absolutely silly
the public schools yeah that's one of
their agenda items it's like are you
serious are you really do you want
nobody going to your school we just
passed uh the biggest school choice bill
into law
uh in this last session in the last
couple weeks that the money follows the
student arizona is the leader in this
now so if you've got ian has a son or
daughter and you don't like what they're
teaching in school up the road you say
you know what we're taking the money our
tax money we're going to this school and
it's huge so this is this is the
craziest thing i'm a huge fan of school
choice
because uh we saw the supreme court
ruling up in maine for instance where
they said in certain areas of maine they
don't have public schools
so the taxpayer is given essentially a
voucher to choose where they want to go
maine was like okay but you can't go to
religious institutions supreme court
said you can't do that that's that's
meddling that's you know but you could
send him to an international school
right
so now we're so we see that the left
freaks out we see uh in florida i think
florida just did a school choice thing
or they're moving towards it and they
i'm wondering how are the democrats
going to try and spin school choice as a
bad thing
and what they're saying is
republicans are going to enact school
choice
then
once parents start leaving public
schools they're going to say oh look
nobody needs public schools and they're
going to shut them all down
so that kids are dumb it's the weirdest
non-argument the reality is there's no
argument against school choice it makes
no sense
there's public schools
parents get a choice in which public
school they go to if you poll people on
this
it's overwhelming democrat independent
and republicans want it so you go well
how come it's taken this long to get it
because the democrats are getting money
from the teachers union a lot of money
is at stake here
this money does not belong to the public
schools
the the money we pour in for education
belongs to the students it's for the
students and for a long time they've
convinced people it belongs to the
public schools no that money we are
taxed and that money goes set aside to
educate our students
it doesn't mean it goes to the public
school there's nothing that says it goes
to the public school if republicans and
conservatives win on the school front
they win period it's over
liberals are not having kids
conservatives are even having less kids
but they have way more so the only way
in the next 10 to 20 years the
conservatives lose is if they don't
inspire young people
so
people really need to think about this
too because so many people don't
10 years ago we've got barack obama's
second term right and you you were how
old you were like 11
yeah not even voting you're just trying
to make me feel old over here with her
well we're old too but my point is
you got to understand 10 years goes in
the blink of an eye
i mean
i i can't believe occupy wall street was
was 11 years ago it's 11 years that's
that's crazy and the the political
issues that we were dealing with that we
were concerned about
gen z has no idea what any of that is
so you don't know anything about occupy
wall street i'd imagine right i don't
mean that in a disrespectful way i mean
like you were a little kid you probably
weren't paying attention yeah i mean
after the fact i i've heard about it
sure but at the time no idea so this is
something that's come up on the show and
we had um i think it was vosh socialist
we had him on the show avalon too young
hunter avalon yeah well it was vosh as
well oh was it really i think both ages
they yeah they're similar ages and
because they're in their 20s and i said
i don't understand how people could be
could vote for joe biden after
everything we went through during the
obama era and with with you know during
occupy wall street obama was the bad guy
obama was the bailout guy i know you can
blame george bush for a lot of the stuff
too and you go back to 2000 but obama
was
was obama the drone guy and the response
we get from him is oh i was in high
school i don't know any of that stuff i
never thought of that you're right
so i have no idea so here's what happens
conservatives have a bunch of kids
elon musk he's cranking out the babies
all that that's the first thing because
those kids are going to retain some of
the values of their parents some
many of these parents are taking their
kids and they're putting them into
institutionalized learning facilities
that hate you
that want to indoctrinate your kids if
the conservatives win on school choice
it's done
the left their dogma their cult will die
with them as they age and they lose
voting power
and the new generation raised by
typically raised by conservatives will
retain conservative values give it 20
years and we're going to see two
generations step up into the vote to
voting age and if the conservatives keep
having their kids and protecting them
from these institutionalized learning
facilities the united states hands down
becomes a christian conservative nation
now i'm not saying it's a good thing for
those that aren't christian conservative
but that's what will happen if christian
conservative parents instill their
values in their kids
that's interesting do you know that uh
since the roe v wade news uh the rate of
vasectomies has like skyrocketed and i'm
sure every conservative is laughing and
high-fiving their friends
because they're the anti-life side
sadly if you i i said this ten years ago
to people i said it a few years ago
if you are
even one percent more likely to get an
abortion
let's say you have 100 let's say you
have 50 democrats and 50 conserva
republicans
and the democrats
are one percent more likely to have an
abortion over a long enough period of
time the democrats will cease to exist
and the republicans will keep having
kids because it's just basic math but it
doesn't matter it's not just abortion
though they're also i'm hearing a lot of
people saying that are liberals saying i
don't want to have kids because of the
climate change and i'm just worried
about the climate
they have been brainwashed into thinking
that it's a bad idea to have children
and it's one of the greatest gifts that
i believe god gives you is when he makes
you a parent well they're also some of
these parents are sterilizing their kids
oh with the the puberty blocks
transgender stuff puberty blockers
things like that and doctors who go
along with that
um really we need to look at their
medical license it's what the surgeries
especially are especially minors so you
look at where we're going and this is
why i stress again the school issue is
the most important i don't know if
conservatives totally get it but the way
you uh that is a great point i mean that
was that was deep and that was true the
saying is
socialists don't have kids they have
yours
if people are conservative and they have
kids and they put them in a college
don't be surprised when your young
beautiful blonde daughter comes home
with a shaved head tattoos gauges and is
screaming that you're evil
this is the craziest thing because i've
seen these stories where a guy you know
he posts on reddit and he's like my
daughter came back from college and she
hates me i don't understand yeah and it
takes they go there in august and by
thanksgiving they come back and they've
changed yep
gotta protect him yeah i think it's
great and we're on the way we're doing
great things in arizona the charter move
school movement really began and we are
going to be the school i call it school
freedom education freedom state and any
way we can make that better so that our
kids are getting a quality education not
a brainwashing and in in my plan for
education is we have what we'd like to
push is a dual track education so after
10th grade you decide hey we're going to
go the the four-year college route or do
we want to go and get skills training
trade school vocational certification
there's no reason we can't get our kids
out of school at 18 and have them ready
to take on the world most of these jobs
don't require college as a matter of
fact college sets you back from
achieving the american dream because
you're in a heap of debt and look at you
know what do we say 18 years old james
monroe these young founding fathers of
ours were doing big things created a
country yeah it took on a monarchy yeah
wow yeah so we need to get our kids
ready at 18. i talk to industry leaders
every week and they say we we've got
great jobs they pay 80 000 full benefits
you know what nobody to fill them you
know what kids need
jobs
the jobs are out there but they're not
ready for them right we should get them
ready in high school i mean
children need jobs oh and but i'll
clarify too because i know that the left
loses their minds because some
republicans said that and they're like
child labor in the mines oh man we
worked so hard as kids i mean up at 6am
on the weekend chores it was crazy
exactly so i worked at my family's
business my mom opened a cafe didn't
survive all that long but a couple years
and uh i think i worked something like
10 hours a week
working with the family business
that is what kids need you don't want
kids doing back breaking labor you don't
work in factories and anything crazy
like that i was making sandwiches and
ringing ringing up people's coffee but
you want some responsibility they can do
some back-breaking work there's not a
damn thing wrong with that oh no of
course of course like i mean dad's dad's
teaching their kid to chop lumber yeah
kids mowing the lawn kids carrying stuff
and moving bricks that's all fine i'm
just like industrial machinery there's a
reason why hey we don't want the kids
well we don't want our kids going off to
work in a factory at age nine and 10. no
but we wanted we were little my dad
would wake us up we heated our home
partially in the winter with wood and so
we had to you know split wood and cut
down trees and do all that and it was
puppets
at the time i i dreaded it i'm sure i
complained the entire day we'd get up at
six a.m we're there you know what we
were paid
a soda we'd go to the gas station after
we were done and we would you know put
you know whatever it was at the time 50
cents or whatever into the you know pop
machine and that was our pay for working
from like
six to three or four in the afternoon
cutting wood cutting lumber and then
splitting wood and loading wood into the
truck and then unloading the wood but
i'm so glad i have
that understanding of how to do that
kids need work they need to you know
paper routes they used to do we don't
have that anymore we need things like
that the greatest thing about a paper
route
it was the collection part do you
remember i mean i don't know if you're
old enough to remember that the paper
boy would you know ride his bike throw
the paper and then at the end of the
week when we were little he'd have to
come knocking at the door and collect
you know whatever the payment was for
the paper that week yeah can you imagine
you're doing like you know debt
collection at age 10.
when i was i was a kid we would go
door-to-door mowing lawns and shoveling
snow
that was like a normal thing where i
grew up
so whenever would snow we'd be we'd get
excited and be like let's go make some
money we can make some dough yeah and
then we'd knock and like you know some
middle-aged dude would come out and we'd
be like we wanna can we shovel your
walkway for money and it's like i give
you 10 bucks and we're like yes got it
that's awesome i wonder do kids still do
that did you do that you know anybody
who does that my brothers definitely did
yeah yeah that's good things like that
are good kids need that stuff i wish we
would have done more of that with our
kids if they're watching they're
probably like mom please don't talk
about us don't but we didn't push that
we didn't have to do that with our kids
and i i regret that we weren't pushing
more of you know work around the house
and things like that both of my kids do
work so that's great
um but they're just so afraid to let
their kids out of the bubble i think
that's it the stranger danger is huge
now oh yeah i never really taught my
kids that because i didn't want them to
look around and be afraid of people i
mean there are obviously bad people in
this world in the public schools i
wanted to know if they ever got lost and
where you know you're at a ballpark or
whatever and they got lost i wanted them
to know that you know what 99.9 of the
people if you just go up and ask them
for help are going to be helpful so i
always train them go find another mommy
yes and tell her you're lost but don't
panic just find another mommy and she'll
help fight you know because i always
knew another mom would help if they see
a child thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast
but if you want to check out the full
show live tune in monday through friday
at 8pm and if you want more special
access content head over to timcast.com
and become a member your membership
helps sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there
you